hayden panettiere talks about the demons
she's battling behind the scenes welcome
everyone to entertainment tonight you
know e.t has been with hayden from the
very start as a child star and remember
the titans to her headlining role in
abc's nashville now she is opening up
about her addiction to drugs alcohol and
the postpartum depression that nearly
cost hayden her life
where did you turn to for support the
bottle the bottom of a bottle i didn't
have any negative feelings towards my
child i just knew i was deeply depressed
and i didn't know where you know the
alcoholism was ending and postpartum was
beginning and i ran myself
pretty ragged it was a battle that
lasted for years hayden confessing i
think i'd hit rock bottom but then
there's that trap door that opens when
you see
a happy-go-lucky girl for years
suddenly
on the floor in a in a puddle of mess
and and alcohol
you got to know something's wrong my
mother was the drug addict murderer not
me turns out in some ways hayden was
living out the storyline of her
character on nashville alcoholism
depression rehab
are you ready
she's very complicated hayden tells
people on stands friday she underwent
trauma therapy and checked herself into
rehab for eight months it was her third
time in treatment it's been such a
an intense year for me we spoke to the
star in 2016 after she shared her
postpartum struggle i am so proud to be
a woman that people can and can look to
and know that they're not alone and
they're not weak if they go and they
seek help as for hayden's seven-year-old
daughter well in 2018 the actress
decided it was best for kaya to live
with her father in ukraine that's former
boxing legend vladimir klitschko
vladimir's brother is the mayor of keeve
and both have been fighting on the front
lines against russia back in 2013 hayden
joined her then fiance at this rally i
support your fight
kai is no longer in ukraine although
it's unclear exactly where she lives now
today hayden is eight months sober and
ready to get back to work get away from
the door charlie the actress tells gma
she fought to return to the big screen
as kirby reed in scream six which is out
in march of next year i called them up
myself and was like so you guys don't
like happen to want to bring kirby back
to you
i did i wanted to be in it that badly i
don't think anyone's going to be
disappointed
[Music]
you